in the Eternal conflict between the High
Heavens and the burning Hells Diablo 4
offers you more Choice than ever before
player choice is infused into everything
from how you look the skills you use the
loot you equip your path through the
non-linear story to how and when you
choose to explore the shared open world
we want players to play their own way
and have their own choice of how they're
going to build their character between
all of our different systems you can
character in ways that we
like Diablo titles
when you log into Diablo 4 the first
thing you're gonna have to do is create
your character and those familiar with
Diablo are going to be very familiar
with the screen with all the classes
sitting around the campfire on Diablo 4
we got five classes the Barbarian is
your fantasy of a fierce Warrior or
fighter The Barbarians the weapon master
of Diablo 4 being able to pick up any
weapon jump into The Fray and do really
badass stuff with it they're very strong
they're very physical they can take
different weapons for different
situations and use them to their maximum
effect the source order is really your
Elemental Mage you have fire ice
lightning you can either focus on one or
you can kind of be a jack of all trades
Mage and use abilities from all three
they're a little more fragile than other
classes tend to be more ranged the Rogue
unlike the Barbarian they are a little
bit more clever they're very fast they
have the ability to imbue their weapons
with different Elemental energies and
they can modify them to do different
things there Rogue has two has two
different types of place
have the ranged
like in your face daggers poisons you
can feed the enemies into traps that
have huge effects more stealthy type
gameplay
the Druid is really the shape shifter
when you cast certain skills you change
your form what you look like and what
you can do they can turn into wear Bears
or werewolves if I cast a werewolf skill
I turn into a werewolf and I do werewolf
things by casts like pulverize for
example which is a wear bear skill I
turn to wear bear I slam the ground
really hard it's the fantasy it's pretty
cool they can also become masters of
nature magic with Earth and storm magic
last but not least we got the
Necromancer they raise armies of the
Dead they have different types of
minions you've got your skeletal
Warriors your skeletal Mages and then
your Golem you have blood magic or bone
magic that you can also take advantage
of and Tackle combat that way if you
played a previous Diablo game and you
enjoyed a certain playstyle you can
actually bring that into Diablo 4 or
just try something completely new no
matter which class you play there's
going to be multiple different Avenues
and Fantasies that you can chase
[Music]
you can customize your character in ways
you've never been able to before with
near endless character creation and
transmog options in previous Diablo
games you had to be attached to certain
archetypes and look a certain way and in
Diablo 4 it's really up to you how you
want your character to look you'll be
able to choose from different facial
structures from people all over the
world no matter where you are you'll be
able to say hey I can actually make
someone that looks like me or looks like
someone from my part of the world which
we're really proud of you can pick a
hairstyle for your character and every
class actually has a specific hairstyle
that no other class can use you can pick
your eye color we have some really fun
ones we have eye glowing we have a
bloodshot type I and then you can
actually pick a marking which is a
tattoo or design that covers your entire
character and there are dozens of those
transmog is the idea that you can take a
piece of gear and change the appearance
of it to look like a different piece of
gear as far as Aesthetics the sky is the
limit however you can think of making
your character you can make it that way
everybody's going to look completely
different in Diablo 4.
of our pillars for classes on ideal
before is this idea that we know that we
players to play the way that they want
to when you first start the game we
introduce you to the idea of the skill
tree as you level up you get access to
these different skills or passives or
upgrades to make your character more
powerful each category has a few
different skills that are all similar
they're either all defensive or all
offensive all ice or all fire you can
either focus on a very specific section
or you can pick and choose the first
skill point when you unlock a new skill
is going to give you access to that
skill after that you can put additional
points into any skill that you have and
it's going to make it better whether it
increases the radius or adds some new
effect or reduces the cooldown through
some special way but you can actually
Branch out in a very different direction
even if two characters actually started
at the same place the perryon board is a
late game system that once you've
completely filled out your skill tree
you think you have a build it will
really let you delve into the theory
crafting and the depth of Diablo 4 skill
system and these boards they can move
through them spending their Paragon
points and they have nodes that give
them very basic stats like intellect or
dexterity we also have more powerful
nodes we have rare nodes that have
different effects where they can totally
modify a skill to do something
additional or different or they can even
make new connections between skills so
that players can have new ways to play
character legendary nodes are equivalent
to Legendary powers where they have more
powerful effects that can change the
builds and ways that characters play
you can start planning this long journey
of okay I want to hit this node and then
I want to hit this node I'm going to
apply this board and I'm going to start
from this side and really just get into
a super complex very specific build for
your character
legendary items are really rare and
Powerful items that you're going to find
As You Adventure through the world of
sanctuary we have quite a few different
categories of legendaries and how they
do that some of them will actually
change your skill or enhance it in some
way Frozen orb for example it might say
hey every single time you use your
Frozen orb it applies a new effect and
then I can actually take advantage of
that new effect that it has even if item
itself is maybe not as good as the one
you have you can still extract That
Power from it take advantage of it and
use it for your build one thing that our
players can look forward to is that a
lot of our classic really rare and most
powerful items from previous titles are
going to be returning as uniques in
Diablo 4. unique items are very similar
to legendaries but they're unique which
means if that ability is actually on a
chess piece it's always going to be on
that chest piece because it's more
powerful than a regular legendary effect
crafting is a big part of Diablo 4. we
have all kinds of different ways that
you could upgrade and interact with NPCs
to make your gear better you can
increase the item level or power of your
gear so you can actually get a piece of
gear and just make it stronger you can
also add sockets to your gear so that
you can put gems inside of it there are
a lot of different ways that players
will be able to customize their
experience in Diablo 4. every single
player is going to have a different
experience and a different build at the
end of the day because we have all of
these different ways to make your own
character there's a lot more possibility
compared to previous titles of how you
want to play how you want to build your
character we really are doubling down on
this idea that you can look the way you
want you can play the way you want you
can really make your own fantasy in this
game hell welcomes all and so does
Diablo 4. in the coming weeks we'll be
sharing even more about how to play your
way our launch on June 6 is getting
closer closer still if you got Early
Access and we can't wait to see you in
sanctuary hail Lilith Blessed Mother